cela fait plusieurs mois que ces
étudiants volontaires travaillent sur le
projet une pièce de théâtre de 35 pages
qui retrace le premier procès de
nuremberg la démarche est une démarche
qui a commencé il ya plus de trois ans
avec l'idée de combiner théâtre droit et
santé il ya deux ans la thématique fut
celle des procédés médecins nazis
n'étaient pas tous nazis d'ailleurs des
médecins dans deux procès de nuremberg
gaumont entre 46 et 47 on a évidemment
tout ce qu'on retrouve dans un tribunal
à savoir l'accusation la défense les
juges et donc les accusés que nous
représentons derrière un procès qui
condamnait les médecins nazis et qui est
à la naissance de la bio éthique
médicale pour la première fois la
question du consentement dans les
expérimentations sont abordés
l'important c'est de soulever le débat
parce que la question des
expérimentations médicales est toujours
d'actualité et aussi de comprendre à
quel point une médecine pourtant
exemplaire qui était celle allemande a
pu se pervertir ça mais au centre l'idée
que le patient doit donner son accord et
doit être volontaire et cette notion de
volontariat notamment qu'il est au
centre de toutes les questions lorsqu'on
est enfermé dans un camp de
concentration est quelque chose qui est
vraiment inscrits dans un code et ce
code finalement va compléter le serment
d'hippocrate et s'appliquer à la
recherche biomédicale les professeurs à
l'initiative du projet souhaité
transformer la transmission du savoir en
plongeant les étudiants directement dans
l'histoire le but moderniser
l'apprentissage à travers le travail de
la représentation théâtrale et bah c'est
eux qu'on entend c'est eux qui font
sonner ses mots et donc pour
l'enseignant basse l'action passionnant
de voir pour se matérialiser finalement
un certain nombre de concepts d'idées à
travers la bouche des étudiants ça une
grande résonance nous dans nos
spécialités médicales c'est que on sait
à quel point il est important
actuellement d'avoir le consentement des
patients travaille avec des étudiants
c'est super de pouvoir travailler avec
des jeunes qui ont envie ce qu'en fait
ce sont vraiment porté volontaire pour
le faire
et que ça anime de restituer sa sur
scène voilà il était super enthousiates
d'autres représentations sont prévues
par la suite et seront suivies de débats
sur la bioéthique
[Applaudissements]